in Benny they have changed the way they
bury the dead
there is no ceremony here no public
prayers for a baby who died at
childbirth a relative is allowed to
approach the body while a man in a
protective suit disinfects the path and
she takes a brief look at a little girl
suspected of contracting Ebola but she
cannot touch the body and she's not
allowed to linger the virus lives long
after its host has passed away Forest
Road on Jerry
SEO NEPA Protege co2 cirrhotic show I
always gave Rav
the coffin is loaded on the back of a
pickup and driven through town on its
way to a graveyard in the forest and the
locals keep their distance
most here are afraid and some simply
don't want to know one reason why the
World Health Organization has
reclassified this crisis as a global
emergency the body is carried into this
burial field and relatives of the dead
are told to keep their distance it's a
breach of tradition and it's traumatic
for some like the grandmother of the
little girl
[Music]
typically loved ones touch or embrace
the body it's their way the family of
Masika mati have followed the rules
they've allowed the Red Cross to bury
the child but there are many Congolese
who have not and it's fueled the spread
of Ebola just allowing somebody else to
handle that body is a leap even if it is
an enormous change and where we have
seen the community second charge it
begins to change without ceremony the
Mattie family left and the people who
work here kept digging that won't be the
last burial that's performed today these
workmen have got 10 graves to dig and
tomorrow they'll clear another section
of the forest if they're going to stop
Ebola it has to start here but
persuading the people to say goodbye
like this is proving extraordinarily
difficult John Sparkes Sky News in Beni